if you came to this area two months ago
you would have found a 407 hectare lake
accol
instead there is now a giant dried-up
land where dozens of species of fish and
flamingos once made their home drought
has been a major problem here in turkey
especially in its eastern cities like
one aziz jalen's family has lived near
lake akko for more than 70 years he's
not happy with the change
we don't have drinking water we have
access to the city water but even before
we tap they cut off you see the animals
you see the grass we have no barley no
grass left if it continues like this we
will all die our animals will die we may
need to leave this village but go where
we're waiting for god's mercy
lake actual was on the migration path of
various types of birds and featured
several species of flamingos like many
other lagoons and lakes in the spacing
watching them used to be a visual feast
aqua lake has a 9 kilometer coastline
but after this year's lack of rain the
lake has shrunk and dried up here is a
closed basin meaning there isn't any
other water source to feed the lake
experts warn after this year's dry up
the lake may never be full of water
again
professor morat tunjurek is head of the
agriculture faculty at the university of
van he says less an irregular
precipitation and higher temperatures
are the reasons for the drought in the
basin
uncharacteristically the temperature is
three to four degrees higher this year
in the lake van basin generally wheat
and barley are dry farmed here plants
that are supposed to be 60 centimetres
long came out as only 20 centimetres
this year we used to have bigger
harvests but this year it's down a lot
and all of it became fodder
groundwater in aquifers is an important
resource for crop irrigation and turkey
but crop production could be threatened
if drought conditions persist
livestock raising will also be affected
some irrigation methods in this part of
turkey cause 60 of water loss
it will lead the food prices to increase
this means costs will go up for
livestock raising and agriculture in a
couple of months what we as citizens
need to do is first of all save on water
local authorities also should reuse
surface waters for irrigation
lake van is the largest body of water in
turkey and the second largest in the
middle east
it's rich in sodium carbonate and other
salts
according to nasa's earth observatory
lake van is evaporating because it has
no outlet to release water cinnamon al
jazeera von turkey